depth as in one of the four horsemen of
the apocalypse is your anti hero for
this installment of the dark Sider
series Darksiders 2 blends action combat
Zelda style dungeon puzzles and
role-playing game mechanics into a very
unique action-adventure game we spoke to
producer J fit sloth about why
Darksiders 2 is one of THQ's biggest
games at this year's e3 she kept the
same basic elements that we from dark
stairs one that we feel a dark siders
title what it is and those three things
are combat traversal and exploration and
puzzle-solving so Darksiders 2 still has
that blend of those elements but we've
increased all of them and then we've
added a lot of new features to kind of
uh panting with Darksiders 2 so we've
got stuff like level and experience
system randomly generated boot when you
kill creatures open chest there's like
literally hundreds of thousands of
different items to find it's a much
bigger world we've got side quests we've
got areas to explore so it's the same
basic feel of darksiders one but just a
much larger and broader game with with
even more elements than the first game
had if you can believe that we consider
it an action-adventure game but we feel
that kind of genre is kind of lost its
way where action-adventure really not
commonly means an action game where
there's some items that you pick up here
and there that change from things where
we want to make it it's an adventure
game first almost adventure action where
there's so much to explore so much to
discover that it adds a lot of
replayability and you know it's worth
going off the beaten path and darksiders
to death has a lot of different weapon
types so there's the size as dual size
those with a standard methods you know
the ones you start with then there's two
classes of secondary weapons there's
heavy weapons and light weapons there's
this wide variety so there's something
for what you would gravitate towards
you'll find it within
Darksiders 2 well what sets Darksiders 2
apart is it has so many elements and so
much going on that it's practically its
own genre people who play the game it
never gets old because there's always
something new going on there's something
new to discover we'll throw a curveball
at you and all of a sudden you're doing
something different than you had the
entire game so when somebody plays the
game it's an easy game to get wrapped up
in because it's so unique and as so many
elements combines everything so well
that it's it's really unlike anything
else out there